une exclusivité pour téléfootin des
retrouvailles en réalité entre deux des
plus grands joueurs de la Coupe du monde
le meilleur buteur de tous les temps est
celui qui est considéré surtout comme le
plus grand joueur de tous les temps
juste fontaine interroge Pelé
quel était le niveau de ce Mondial
comme la le premier match Allemagne
Hollande nous a fait un peu peur
que le niveau de cette année a été
meilleur que celui de 1974 en Allemagne
[Musique]
qui se classe parmi les quatre
finalistes c'est très important
mais nous autres brésiliens nous sommes
habitués à avoir une équipe qui est
toujours dans les premières
une équipe avec de bons avant et cette
fois nous avons une bonne défense c'est
pour cette raison que cela n'a pas pu au
spectateur
pour la Coupe du Monde
terminée quatrième ou troisième je crois
que c'est une bonne chose
quelle est l'équipe qui vous a le plus
impressionné
en finale
par exemple au début l'Autriche a
présenté un bon football le Pérou qui a
très bien commencé
France La France a un bon football mais
ces équipes ne sont pas parvenues en
pôle final par manque d'expérience
[Musique]
celui qu'elle avait en 1974 mais elle a
présenté un bon football et l'Argentine
m'a plu par sa force sa manière de
lutter de courir et puis par deux ou
trois individualités
l'Argentine joue comme les Européens
l'entraîneur de l'Argentine mais
nautique
transformée l'équipe parce qu'il a fait
œuvre de créateurs
habile il a créé une équipe qui s'engage
plus physiquement avec des passes
longues plus offensives cela a été la
plus grande surprise de cette coupe du
monde
lorsque vous assistez à une football
vous avez vraiment envie de rejouer
maintenant très souvent par exemple lors
de Brésil Espagne
avait l'occasion de gagner et que
l'Espagne pratiquait un jeu défensif et
que le Brésil n'arrive pas à conclure
moi j'avais envie d'entrer sur le
terrain avec le Brésil mais la même
chose dont vous arrivez mais moi je peux
plus courir
de jouer au football de temps en temps
il a une chaise en France on se demande
si un jour nous verrons peler en
entraîneur ou directeur national de
l'équipe brésilienne
on a beaucoup parlé de cela avant ce
Mondial
je ne pense pas à Fontaine
professionnel je ne crois pas
cela pourrait se faire dans quatre cinq
ou six ans mais maintenant non si je
travaille c'est avec des jeunes des
amateurs
mais pas des professionnels
on peut toujours beaucoup de choses
aujourd'hui vous savez que les
entraîneurs nationaux ne font pas ce
qu'ils veulent ils sont confrontés à des
problèmes de pression d'argent de
méthodes de travail ils doivent obéir
des directives et moi si je deviens
entraîneur
et si je travaille je veux faire ce que
je veux c'est très difficile
il faut il faut laisser la liberté aux
joueurs actuellement les joueurs doivent
obéir avec les mains l'entraîneur car
s'ils ne le font pas ils sont renvoyés
[Applaudissements]
parce que vous avez apporté au football
[Musique]
cela m'a fait plaisir et puis et puis
j'ai commencé avec toi
merci beaucoup
[Musique]